a special discount for an olaf shoal's
haircut a little joke from barbara
bachchad algon to celebrate the new
chancellor who happens to be an old
friend they met when both were working
for the sbd the social democratic party
in hamburg
it's a special day because my good
comrade my very sensible convert will be
in a powerful position as chancellor and
i will keep my fingers crossed
then drink it down
i can't even explain how special this
day is for me
63 year old schultz who was raised by
social democratic parents joined the sbd
at the age of 17. after working as a
labor law attorney he was elected mayor
in hamburg in 2011.
leading germany's second largest city
schultz showed himself as a pragmatic
and at times tough mayor he came under
fire when rioting broke out during the
2017 g20 summit in the city
it's here in hamburg where olaf schultz
was tested as a politician and a leader
now he has to show not only can he lead
germany but also guide the eu through
difficult times tackling the covet 19
pandemic and security threats at its
borders schultz will lead a three-party
government with the greens and the
liberal fdp a novelty in germany the
coalition has announced an ambitious
177-page deal that should modernize
germany by speeding up the energy
transition and improve welfare provision
but it's the deadly fourth wave of the
coveted pandemic that will need all his
attention first we need to be able to
make the decisions fast and that also
means he has to lead the coalition and
not go into endless debates and and
compromises with half of his cabinet
posts given to women charles wants to
show he is serious about change his
foreign minister annaleina bierbach of
the greens has announced the toughest
stance on russia and china but some
wonder if scholes has what it takes to
lead internationally i think his lack of
charisma is a weakness
now
his
his advisers keep telling us that this
is going to be a strong chancellor that
can bring people together and that
behind the scenes he is the person that
can do that but certainly he hasn't
shown that he can convey
and can bring people behind him germany
will find out soon enough because the
country takes over the g7 presidency in
january an important moment for schultz
to convince those who still have doubts
patchat algon has none
he listens takes it in and does not
forget he will think about it before he
makes a decision that is olaf and he
should just stay olaf then he can do
anything
above all algon hopes a new chancellor
won't forget his old friends and will
still visit him for some good advice
stop fasting al jazeera hamburg